la otan mandará nuevos sistemas de
defensa antiaérea a Ucrania ante la
escalada de la ofensiva de Moscú que
ataca población civil Incluso en la
región de kiev el jefe de la alianza
atlánticaltenberg dijo que solo usaría
armas nucleares en circunstancias
remotas
el Jurado recomendó cadena perpetua para
Nicolas Cruz el autor de la masacre de
la escuela de parkland Florida en 2018
Cruz fue declarado culpable del
asesinato con un rifle de asalto de 14
estudiantes y tres empleados del Centro
Educativo tenemos el reporte desde
Florida
se cumple un mes de la detención de la
joven kurdo iraní maxamí quien falleció
bajo custodia de la policía de la moral
la muerte de amenia ha desatado
protestas masivas contra el régimen de
Irán ampliamos desde Teherán
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de Franz 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
mateu y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
empezamos esta edición con noticias de
la guerra en Ucrania kiev denunció este
jueves nuevos ataques rusos con drones
en la región de kiev y bombardeos en
Nicolás en el sur del país ante la
escalada de la ofensiva de Moscú la otan
enviará sistemas de defensa antiaérea
Ucrania por otro lado el kremlin
advirtió que el ingreso de Ucrania a la
alianza atlántica desataría la tercera
guerra mundial más en el siguiente
informe de Marta Moya
las sirenas antiaéreas volvieron a sonar
en kiev a primera hora de la mañana de
este jueves horas más tarde el
presidente ruso Vladimir Putin se reunía
en kazajistán con su homólogo Turco Rey
Perdón para debatir sobre cuestiones
energéticas y estrechar lazos con la
escalada bélica como telón de fondo en
el terreno las autoridades ucranianas
denunciaron un ataque con drones
kamikaze de fabricación iraní en la
región capitalina miko Life una urbe al
sur del país fue blanco de nuevos
bombardeos más de 100 misiles rusos han
impactado en Ucrania desde el lunes
según el gobierno de bolodimir zelenski
que aprovechó su participación en el
consejo de Europa para pedir más
sistemas de defensa aérea
[Música]
queremos tener la capacidad de cerrar el
cielo nuestras capacidades No son
suficientes Alemania abrió el camino a
esta posibilidad proporcionándonos el
primer sistema iristete Estados Unidos
confirmó su apoyo con escudos
antimisiles nasams Nos gustaría que este
apoyo fuera mucho mayor por su parte
desde Moscú denunciaron ataques
ucranianos en un edificio Residencial en
la ciudad de belgorot próxima a harkie
pero del lado ruso de la frontera
un artefacto desconocido cayó después de
que se activaran las defensas aéreas los
años pueden verse aquí en el lugar en el
último piso
en la región de gerson una de las cuatro
provincias anexionadas unilateralmente
por Rusia el gobernador local pidió al
kremlin evacuar a la población civil por
las arremetidas de las tropas ucranianas
los objetivos que alcanzan los misiles
son hoteles casas residenciales mercados
donde hay muchos civiles
[Música]
mientras la guerra avanza los miembros
de la otan reunidos en Bruselas
afirmaron su apoyo aquí es por tiempo
indefinido
en otras noticias Corea del Sur reportó
que Corea del Norte disparó un nuevo
misil balístico hacia las aguas
surcoreanas orientales además las
autoridades de seúl informaron que las
fuerzas de pyongyang han hecho volar
aviones de combate cerca de la frontera
entre las dos coreas sin embargo no se
han registrado enfrentamientos entre los
dos ejércitos recordemos que en las
últimas dos semanas el líder norcoreano
Kim Jong ha dirigido una serie de
lanzamientos de misiles algunos de los
cuales cayeron acerca de Japón también
Corea del Norte aseguró que estos
lanzamientos son una respuesta a los
ejercicios militares conjuntos de seúl y
Washington
vamos ahora a Estados Unidos donde los
doce miembros del Jurado recomendaron
cadena perpetua para Nicolás Cruz el
autor de la masacre en la escuela de
parkland de Florida en 2018 cruz de 24
años enfrenta 17 cargos por homicidio
tras disparar con un rifle de asalto en
un edificio de la escuela secundaria
Marjorie Stone Man Douglas El joven y
hace declaró culpable el año pasado de
asesinar a 14 estudiantes y tres
empleados del Centro Educativo la juez
dictará la sentencia el próximo 1 de
noviembre previamente desde la ciudad de
Miami en el estado de Florida nuestro
corresponsal alto nivelche nos daba los
detalles efectivamente los 12 miembros
del Jurado han recomendado que se
dictamine esa cadena perpetua para
Nicolás Cruz acusado de 17 cargos por
homicidio en primer grado Aparentemente
es una decisión que ha sorprendido
muchos de los presentes en la sala
principalmente a los padres de esos
niños que murieron en la masacre de
principalmente porque solo han tardado
estos miembros del Jurado siete horas en
tomar esta decisión de que se dictamine
cadena perpetua para Nicolás Cruz hay
que recordar que para que se llegue a un
acuerdo se la decisión Del Jurado debe
ser unánime de acuerdo a las leyes de la
Florida y que recordar también que la
pena capital en Florida es una pena que
lleva instalada desde
1923 que es Florida es el cuarto estado
con mayores ejecuciones desde
1976 y es una medida muy popular entre
los residentes de Florida por lo tanto
esa sorpresa entre muchos de los
presentes pero también entre muchas de
las personas que estaban siguiendo esta
decisión del Jurado en televisión sean
paralizado todas las conexiones en
televisión para seguir este esta
decisión Del Jurado ante esa sorpresa
hay que recordar que el 14 de febrero de
2018 Nicolás Cruz ha armado con un rifle
de asalto dentro en esa escuela de
parkland al norte de Miami matando a 14
alumnos y tres personas del
staff de la escuela
cambiamos de información en Francia un
30% de las gasolineras tienen escasez de
combustible una falta causada por las
huelgas de los empleados de la
refinerías en los depósitos de las
petroleras total y Epson Mobile mientras
El Ejecutivo obligó a algunos
trabajadores a volver a sus puestos de
trabajo otras empresas energéticas
francesas podrían unirse a las
movilizaciones
y se cumple un mes desde la detención de
la joven kurdo iraní maxa Amin Quien
murió bajo custodia de la policía de la
moral el 16 de septiembre desde entonces
la muerte de ha desatado un movimiento
masivo dentro y fuera de Irán contra el
régimen de la República islámica nuestra
corresponsal enteran Catalina Gómez
Ángel nos hace un repaso de lo
acontecido durante el mes
sin duda el sistema de la República
islámica no ha entendido incluso todavía
la dimensión de la indignación y de la
rabia que tuvo un gran sector de la
población especialmente joven y
especialmente mujer cuando se conoció lo
que había pasado con maxam y una joven
de 22 años que estaba de visita en
Teherán caminaba por la ciudad cuando
fue detenida por una de esas patrullas
de la moral y dos horas más tarde era
llevada con muerte cerebral al hospital
muchas de esas jóvenes que están en la
calle han sido víctimas también de esas
patrullas y saben que muchas veces
actúan de manera violenta y algunos
testigos aseguran que esta mujer fue
golpeada aunque las autoridades todavía
aseguran que ella murió como
consecuencia de una enfermedad que tuvo
en su infancia lo que crea mayor
indignación dentro de la población que
sigue protestando no solamente en
Teherán sino las grandes ciudades del
país y esto se hace especialmente
evidente en la región del kurdistán de
donde es originaria
de la represión ha aumentado incluso más
en los últimos días se habla de grandes
enfrentamientos se habla de patrullas de
la policía yendo a sacar a personas de
sus casas explosiones y se habla de
menos 5000 detenidos solamente en esa
zona del país hoy hablaba el jefe de la
justicia iraní y decía que los
principales protagonistas de estas
movilizaciones de estos disturbios como
los llaman tenían que tener fuertes
sentencias que así se lo había ordenado
a sus jueces y que el resto de la
población que está así aparte de ellos
tenía que ser juzgado y salir
rápidamente pero también el debate que
se ha creado en estas últimas semanas es
el velo a estas horas muchas mujeres
caminan por las calles de Teherán y de
las grandes ciudades sin velo y el uno
de los asesores del líder supremo de la
Revolución exporta vos del parlamento
alilar y Yani hablaba de que si el 50%
de las mujeres no quieren usar el velo
habría que abrir esa conversación porque
no se le pueden poner a importante que
hacer Así que el debate está abierto
falta ver que dice la parte más radical
de la República islámica y saber cómo
van a seguir gestionando estas protestas
vamos a Turquía porque el parlamento
Turco aprobó una polémica ley contra la
desinformación un texto que la oposición
califica de herramienta de censura que
el gobierno podría usar para acallar las
voces disidentes sobre todo de Cara a
las elecciones del año que viene la ley
todavía no ha sido firmada por el
presidente erdogan y partidos de la
oposición ya anunciaron que llevarán la
legislación ante la justicia desde
Estambul adria Rocha con los detalles
El parlamento Turco ha aprobado hoy una
nueva ley contra la desinformación que
según los críticos de este nuevo texto
será una ley de censura Según esto el de
texto de esta nueva ley el gobierno y el
sistema judicial Turco podrá condenar
apenas de hasta tres años de cárcel a
cualquiera que Esparza o publique
información que sea dirimida como falsa
podrán ser tantos ciudadanos como
también periodistas quién decidirá qué
es qué noticia Cuál es verdadera será el
propio gobierno de reset type erdogan
que explica según este texto que también
podrán ser investigadas y condenadas
personas que retuiteen en esta supuesta
información falsa partidos opositores
han asegurado que después de votar en
contra de esta ley que ha sido probada
igualmente apelarán al tribunal
constitucional para que intente revocar
esta ley que aún no ha sido firmada por
el gobierno de presidente Turco recepta
y perdón en cuanto lo sea han dicho los
opositores intentarán apelar contra esta
nueva ley que los defensores de los
Derechos Humanos
libertad de expresión aseguran que viene
justo antes de momento crucial para
Turquía aseguran estas organizaciones
que el gobierno quiere silenciar las
voces críticas que se levantan ahora
mismo en contra de erdogan en un momento
en que llegan elecciones presidenciales
en primavera de este año según la gran
mayoría de las encuestas el presidente
Turco perdería esos comicios ante una
posición cada vez más fuerte y según
estas organizaciones el gobierno querría
callar estas voces tanto de periodistas
como de ciudadanos ante un momento clave
para Turquía
y el parlamento ir aquí eligió al
político kurdo Abdul latifrasis como el
nuevo presidente del país una decisión
que allá en el camino para la formación
de un nuevo gobierno para poner fin a un
año de bloqueo político el nuevo
mandatario ya designó al político
alineado con Irán Mohamed shield sudany
para que intente formar el nuevo
ejecutivo del país recordemos que la
candidatura de al sudanía Primer
Ministro provocó intensas protestas en
Bagdad entre julio y agosto de este
mismo año de hecho esta mañana al menos
9 proyectiles impactaron cerca del
parlamento irakiv y dejaron heridos a
varios ejecutivos de seguridad y civiles
de momento ningún grupo ha reivindicado
el ataque
Muchísimas gracias por su atención sigan
con nosotros en francés 24 y 24.com
[Música]